where am i going to go with this guy
okay where am i going to go to get
tension am i ready to go to attention
yet
i think so you find a loss
because velocity and
okay so i can find omega i can find
omega because it's
v which i know on r which i know as well
right so i can say omega is going to be
the velocity is yeah you just uh find
omega squared instead so they get rid of
those
yeah i can i can but for now like i mean
i'm i'm i prefer to use these
and then work back to whatever i need
then to like i feel
just too many steps in my head i just
feel too many steps in my head so at
least this
i can go from a straight line from this
line to the next one
rather than oh i squared something in my
head wait did i square it or did i not
square it and i just
get confused okay so i've got v that's
the square root of
g i've got r that's this guy
okay the ratio of two square roots is
the square root of the ratios
so you can say all right i can put a
square root over the whole thing
this is on the denominator so this is
going to on the denominator of the
denominator so it's going to
hop up the top so i've got 2g on
root 17 take away one that's omega and
now as round suggested i actually want
omega squared
so that's neater that's good
like so okay what am i going to do with
this
i lost i can get back to ml omega
squared right
i can say the tension is equal to mass
is four length is two there's
omega squared
uh let's have a look uh huh i don't
believe they did
um i think again they've taken
yeah i know i know i know but if you
want to if you want to make sure you get
this
did i get it right do they zero to match
i've already checked
i've already checked okay so this is
let's just evaluate it
and then we'll leave in terms of g and
then we'll evaluate um so that's 8
16 16 g yes 16g
on this there's our nice precise answer
and then i can say
it's equal to you go ahead and value i
think you get 50.
if
that okay so yeah um
can you tell us what it is after we've
finished the actually we're almost there
okay so i need theater now where would
you like me to go to find theater
oh um it like a previous calculation
where like
um i hold alpha like i tried i just put
alpha in there without calculating it
and the tension equals to like four
times two times g on two cos alpha
so if you just like if you just divide
it by that then
okay so what would you like me to from
here having got the tension
so you've got that what would you like
me to write
how are we going to communicate how we
find out what theta alpha is
yes okay i can say in just in this right
angle triangle
here sine theta equals
opposite opposite on hypotenuse
yes so that's going to be take a breath
uh the square root of the square root of
17 minus one
on two on two
yeah is that okay don't get don't get
intimidated i know the number is messy
but it's still just a number still just
the number just to make it a tiny bit
easier to
input this is a half times this
right so when the half comes in
underneath the square root what does it
become
it becomes a quarter so this is actually
the square root of
square root of 17 take away on eight i
believe
okay that's side b is that okay
so theta is going to be sine inverse of
this side inverse of this
okay now i'm expecting you're in radians
mode has someone got the number
i have a number um that's a good
question
oh they gave him what i know they've
given it in degrees we'll talk about
that in a second but
i think radiance is a better answer um
or a more a more natural answer
rather someone got it
now i'm just going to argue for the fact
i think radians makes
sense because we've got omegas here
which are radians per second
all that kind we're doing calculus i
think radians
is a natural um unit to use
however they have supplied it to us in
degrees at least their answer has
i suppose because people visually you're
like oh how far is that and if you told
someone 0.67 radians
no one would say oh oh no i have an
exact picture in my head right
so they've converted they've multiplied
by one e you're pi which gives
it's like 30 something 30 degrees and
like something
i've got i've got uh 38 degrees i
thought oh yeah and 40 degrees
okay that's what i calculated um as you
guys know that's the point of the
question
okay but um yeah you can provide another
form i think readings makes sense
are there any questions
you had another way do you want to talk
us through it so
how far back do i need to rewind uh to
the beginning so
you still have to do the finding of the
hard bit okay so
so you want to pick up from here oh no
but the the step before
this one no um like complete i started
listening you did a different way
if i start to find heart okay all right
well do you want to talk to it so
first um the linear velocity of the
base circle is root shape
meters per second yep and then um you
know that
the uh circumference of the base circle
is two pi r
so therefore it has to come it okay it's
covering um
two pi r meters in root g meters per
second
so two pi r on root g is equal to the
period
okay so you said v equals root g
so therefore the period is equal to
two pi r on root g
yeah yeah and yeah and then the period
is also
two pi on omega but
yeah and
so therefore two pi on omega equals two
pi
r on g yep so cancel cancel
and then um looks like omega
equals it's the reciprocal it's region r
right haven't i where did i get that i
feel like i've wrote that down somewhere
well maybe i wrote down something since
that's amazing where if i got it in the
second column
second column before flying down all
right
yeah yeah okay so so you got to that
instead of my derivative
you did that just by yeah that's fine
okay keep going and then
um you sub it you have you sub it into
ml
ml t equals ml omega squared
so we already knew that m l was what
four times two so that's
eight times this yeah uh squared
so that's g g on r squared and then yes
that you are something you've got okay
so so then you put that
result in so t equals eight g
on root uh
17 yep
and then it becomes 16 g this is
the same we match up there don't we yeah
there we go that that gets you to here
yeah i'm happy with that i think that's
fine but it's an equally valid
one because then you can win the
quadratic fully yeah that's good avoid
no you started to do a quadratic form oh
no
you did because you still needed you
still needed to sub into there
yeah but you avoided the line of needing
to remember
though i never remembered that okay uh
omega yeah
i i would suggest you actually did
remember it when you did this
like vehicle's iron maker is kind of
implied when you said this
right like it's kind of snuck in do you
see that's you
it's right there do you see it um but
yeah you didn't have to remember it
because it was kind of
tough